[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 26 octobre voici
les titres
elle se réveille à nouveau après dix ans
de mise en sommeil la maison d'emile
zola rouvre à médan c'est ici que
l'auteur de j'accuse a écrit une grande
partie de son oeuvre le lieu se dote
aussi d'un nouveau musée consacré à l'
affaire dreyfus le président de la
république s'y est rendu aujourd'hui
pour l'inauguration + 30 % de bouchons
en ile-de-france par rapport à l'an
passé la circulation s'est densifiée
dans la région en septembre et en
octobre on vous explique tout dans un
instant daniel qui ressort également
avec nous il y le dirigeant de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes
et puis on ne compte plus le nombre de
médailles est réuni hier à poissy des
champions de la natation était présent
pour apprendre aux jeunes à nager à
l'opération aux nageurs et citoyen veut
lutter contre les noyades 300 enfants de
moins de 6 ans sont victimes chaque
année en france
des collégiens qui étudie le blog tout
comme le spationaute thomas pesquet
depuis l'espace on en parle tout à
l'heure dans ce journal
[Musique]
mais d'abord donc cette visite du
président de la république dans les
yvelines emmanuel macron s'est rendu à
médan dans l'après midi
je vous le disais dans les titres
c'était pour l'inauguration de la maison
d'emile zola le site a rouvert après de
longues années dix ans de travaux pour
le refuge de l'écrivain c'est là qu'il a
écrit nombre de ses romans
cette maison des illustres qui rouvre
s'enrichit également d'un musée consacré
à l' affaire dreyfus dont zola a signé
le célèbre tri article j'accuse et avant
la venue sur place du président et avant
même l'ouverture la réouverture au
public de ce lieu qui aura lieu ce jeudi
nous avons pu visiter en avant-première
ce lieu dédié hazolahy dreyfus deux
hommes aux destins liés et c'est nicolas
d'andré qui joue les guides
voilà l'une des citations du célèbre
j'accuse d'emile zola un texte adressé
au président de la république félix
faure à travers la presse le jeudi 13
janvier 1898 l'un des basculements de l'
affaire dreyfus raconté ici dans ce
musée à médan à travers différents
objets historiques du côté de refuser on
est plus sur la pérennité long terme et
on va utiliser le livre la brochure
essentiellement alors que du côté anti
dreyfusards on n'est plus dans
l'immédiateté l'idée c'est de convaincre
le plus rapidement possible d'être
convaincre la rue donc on va avoir comme
ça a énormément de le flyer existe déjà
en fait il est différent il est rond il
est petit on le met rempile en cela un
balcon on le lance et il vole des flyers
pour rappel alfred dreyfus et un
officier français de confession juive il
a été victime d'une machination
antisémite organisé par l'état cette
affaire résonne avec la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et le racisme des sujets
abordés à travers la visite du musée
dreyfus penser avec un volet pédagogique
destiné aux élèves des collèges et
lycées dans le musée on a à travers tout
ce qui est montré les documents la
possibilité de s'appuyer de s'adosser à
la réalité d'une histoire de notre pays
et puis il y aura la possibilité au sous
sol à partir de tutoriels à partir de
films à partir de vidéos d'ados
retravailler tous ces thèmes juste à
côté du musée dreyfus la maison d'emile
zola elle est ouverte au public de 1985
jusqu'en 2011 fermez la bâtisse et
restaurer le musée dreyfus est conçu une
restauration fidèles à l'époque d'emile
zola comme son cabinet le bureau où il a
écrit ses plus grandes oeuvres là vous
êtes dans un lieu de créativité
littéraire un refuge c'est à tour
d'ivoire donc cela arrivait ici au mois
de mai jusqu'au mois de décembre il
écrivait l'équivalent de quatre pages
manuscrites par jour ce n'est pas
beaucoup mais cela ne suffit pas de
décrire il dit toujours qu'il veut bâtir
son oeuvre comme une symphonie musicale
la bête humaine l'assommoir ou germinal
les lignes de ses oeuvres résonne encore
dans ses murs au bonheur des visiteurs
qui pourront découvrir ce site aux
destins liés à partir du 28 octobre 2021
[Musique]
on va parler à présent circulation vous
l'avez sans doute remarqué depuis
septembre il faut s'armer de patience
sur les routes des yvelines la cause
l'augmentation du trafic qui concerne
aussi l'île de france pour nous
décrypter ce phénomène michael et demi
d'euros est avec nous bonsoir bonsoir
journalistes de la rédaction de tv 78
alors est ce que c'est un mirage ou le
temps de trajet a réellement augmenté
pour les franciliens alors les français
ont souvent l'habitude d'un de râler sur
les routes le matin ou le soir mais là
c'est vrai le trafic avait augmenté en
ile-de-france depuis la rentrée il ya eu
des journées exceptionnelles comme le 14
septembre dernier ce jour là on a par
exemple enregistré 6 103 km de bouchons
cumulés à cause de la pluie des
accidents il ya eu également la tempête
aurore qui a perturbé le trafic le 21
octobre mais si on enlève séjourne
exceptionnels là aussi les chiffres sont
clairs le trafic augmenter depuis la
rentrée selon bison futé en septembre il
ya eu une augmentation des
embouteillages de 30% par rapport à 2020
et surtout de 22% par rapport à 2019 une
année orco vides même constat pour
octobre plus d'embouteillages donc et ça
les élus nous allons constater on les
écoute
à cause de la pose de conduites on n'en
est pas du coup tu es plus le mois de
septembre vraiment un beau
but à dix minutes la mimique c'est
saturé tout le temps personnellement je
suis du coin depuis 25 ans alors on a
l'habitude moi je trouve c'est saturé
qu'ils fassent des étages moi je mets
une demi heure de plus de mer depuis sur
tel trajet sur
elancourt
jusqu'à
saint quentin en yvelines enfin
guyancourt
j'ai bruit il faut adapter son planning
en conséquence parce que sinon on est en
retard voilà pour le constat comment on
explique cette augmentation du trafic il
y a plusieurs facteurs selon bison futé
il y a tout d'abord énormément de
travaux dans la région ile de france en
vue notamment des jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024 ce qui entraîne des
rétrécissements sur des axes et donc des
embouteillages la météo est également un
facteur on l'a connu en septembre très
pluvieux ce qui entraîne plus
d'accidents sur les routes là à kovy 19
et le télétravail sont d'autres facteurs
en écoute leur ivax responsable du
service à bison futé dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire il ya une certaine
défiance à l'égard des transports en
commun la part d'un certain nombre
d'usagers qui préfèrent utiliser la
voiture avec phénomène d'auto soliste en
étant seul dans son véhicule plutôt que
d'aller dans des transports en commun
dans le cahier du monde s'expose et
certaine promiscuité et puis un autre
phénomène qui est peut-être un peu moins
intuitif qui est lié au télétravail
c'est à dire que dans la mesure où
certains à certains travailleurs ne vont
que sur site deux ou trois jours par
semaine voire moins il est parfois plus
intéressant d'y aller en voiture que le
délai en transport en commun notamment
pour des raisons économiques parfois le
coût d'abonnement aux transports en
commun est plus élevé que de faire rage
à une ou deux fois par semaine en
voiture est ce que le trafic va
s'améliorer dans les prochaines semaines
mais bien les oreilles pas forcément
selon bison futé il faudra attendre
encore quelques mois pour se faire une
idée le trafic va dépendre notamment des
règles de télétravail et de l'épidémie
de kobe 19h merci michael pour ces
précisions et avec nous par visio
conférence pour parler de ce sujet mais
aussi d'un autre on lui demandera
notamment son avis sur l'indemnité
inflation du gouvernement qui a été
premier pour faire face à cette hausse
des prix c'est daniel guerreau bonsoir
oui bon choix vaty blinois est aussi
dirigeant d'une association
l'association nationale 40 millions
d'automobilistes qui défend justement
les automobilistes c'est un constat
aussi que vous faites depuis quelques
semaines depuis ce mois de septembre une
augmentation du trafic et est-ce que
c'est aussi ce que vous avez constaté en
ile de france oui c'est très clair alors
que beaucoup de gens nous disent que la
voiture c'est plus d'actualité que ça se
réduit c'est exactement la meilleure ce
qui se passe et ceci depuis la pandémie
effectivement les jambes ont pris
l'habitude de colorature parce qu'ils
sont un petit peu peur dans les
transports en commun il ya un autre
phénomène en ile de france vous voyez
l'ile-de-france et 12 millions
d'habitants et deux millions d'habitants
au milieu et on s'aperçoit que ces deux
millions d'habitants paris ve éjecter la
voiture de la ville et ne cesse de créer
des bouchons pour que les gens ne
viennent plus à pas il ya une
interdépendance entre partis et et la
banlieue comme ont gardé ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end vous avez un tunnel
qui est fermé sur le rhin entre le pôle
l'autoroute de l'ouest et le
périphérique wii le bouchon que ça crée
donc à chaque fois on crée des
difficultés au centre de l'île de france
ça serait parti partout laurie tous ces
phénomènes la pandémie plus la création
de travaux et de rue est interdit de
d'empêcher de rouler les voitures mais
en crée les embouteillages de france en
fait donc le fidèle de la 13ème fait
référence qui a été fermée pendant
plusieurs plusieurs heures même
plusieurs jours à cause d'un vol de
câbles et c'est effectivement ça
congestionné une bonne partie du trafic
sur cet axe donc pour vous il ya une
vraie relation entre ces mesures prises
à paris on pense forcément à sept zones
de faibles émissions la vignette
critères aussi qui a été mise en place
la zone 30 il ya un réel lien entre ces
mesures prises à la capitale dans la
capitale sur le reste du trafic en île
de france forcément quand vous êtes et
quand vous empêcher les voitures de
l'entrée dans paris mais réparties j'ai
tout autre lourd ou créent des
embouteillages à une interdépendance on
va très bien sûr blog paris la
périphérie de paris se trouve touché
forcément est ce qu'il ya des zones plus
tendue que d'autres en ile de france on
pense forcément nous dans les yvelines à
cette autoroute 86 qui est la plus la
plus empruntée en france nous allons
nous at on dit quand on a on a enquêté
sur le sujet est ce qu'il ya des points
plus tendue que d'autres en ile de
france dans les yvelines aussi
c'est le même phénomène lors de parry
sound of noise est à dire que doubler
les autos qui convergent vers paris
à partir du moment où elles ont plus de
difficultés les ouvertures opus de
logique et à entrer dans paris ça se
ressent partout c'est facile à
comprendre
est-ce que la solution avec ses défauts
on l'a dit un season de faibles
émissions qui sont mises en place on
sait aussi que dans le même temps il ya
le développement et le déploiement de ce
grand paris alors qu'il verra le jour
qu'à la fin des années 2020 est ce que
finalement
l'idée de laisser de plus en plus sa
voiture est pas une solution qui serait
plus viable dans les prochaines les
prochaines années c'est tout à fait vrai
mais on voit l' usage que c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe alors plutôt
que d'interdire de punir est taxée il
faudrait commencer par offrir des
solutions c'est-à-dire des alternatives
à la mobilité automobile là
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse par
exemple avoir des parcs de stationnement
aux abords de paris à bon marché de
façon à ce qu'on puisse laisser sa
voiture pour des transports en commun
c'est à dire organiser au plus mon tarif
et des transports je ne sais pas on
commence par tenir interdit à taxer et
ça va aller je crois crescendo parce que
pourront regarder ce qui va se passer
avec l'interdiction dédié z en 2024 de
prôner par madame hidalgo vous avez
aujourd'hui 65% du parti et diesel alors
qu'est ce que vont faire les gens y vont
pour être des jeunes on va pas à pouvoir
empêcher ces gens se déplacer donc c'est
un vrai sujet commençons d'abord par
offre des solutions avant de devenir et
l'avenir alors plus de bouchons mais
aussi et c'est dans l'actualité une
flambée des prix à la pompe la semaine
dernière jean castex a annoncé le
déploiement d'une indemnité inflation
100 euros versée automatiquement à 38
millions de français qui gagnent moins
de 2000 euros par mois il s'agit donc
d'une aide ponctuelle qui sera versée
une seule fois à partir de décembre
plutôt qu'une baisse des taxes ou un
chèque aussi carburants qui avait été
évoqué est-ce que c'est mieux que rien
ou c'est pas du tout suffisant à vos
yeux cette mesure devrait on a attendu
un bon moment et on s'est dit on va
avoir une vraie solution est en réalité
et pas un chèque carburant puisque c'est
un chèque espèces de prime de noël sous
conditions de ressources et qui est donc
offerte à tous ceux qui ont ou qui
ou pas d'ailleurs donc on voit bien
qu'on traite pas le problème et en plus
on laisse les entreprises gérées cette
prime de 100 euros c'est vraiment une
construction d'une usine à gaz commence
que le faire il n'y avait qu'une
solution c'était de baisser les taxes
sur les carburants alors je sais que
mercy s'est défendu à cor et à cri de
cette baisse des taxes pourquoi parce
que depuis que le pétrole augmente
depuis que le baril augmente comme la
taxe et ntic paix en plus vous avez de
tva sur l'ensemble de la fac une taxe
sur la taxe ce qui fait que quand le
prix du baril augmente
vous avez un effet levier et les
rentrées dans les caisses de l'état soit
extrêmement important donc faut pas que
monsieur le maire nous disent qu'il n'y
a pas d'argent puisqu'il a perdu
beaucoup d'argent il pouvait en laisser
repartir dans pour la pour à pouvoir
rouler aux automobilistes bordeaux se
pique de prix du baril de pétrole
d'angola on n'a pas traité le problème
et nous on était des blancs third
alertes des gens de mes 18 ouvriers les
prix du plus du carburant monte et à fin
août on avait attiré l'attention du
président public on avait vu des groupes
qui voulait se constituer de chez les
jeunes et sierra on n'a pas écouté et là
on est en train de tirer pour la semaine
des as pour voir les gens ils
considèrent que le prix du carburant est
trop élevé et on n'a pas du tout régler
le problème c'est tout reste à faire
parce que du côté de l'association on
terminera par là vous portez de mesures
notamment la baisse de la tva à 5 5% car
pour vous le carburant c'est un bien de
première nécessité il faut le considérer
comme un bien de première nécessité une
autre mesure c'est la baisse aussi de la
tei cpe qu'est la taxe intérieure de
consommation sur les produits
énergétiques vous voudriez qu'elle soit
aux minima européens à imposer par
justement l'union européenne très
concrètement qu'est ce que ça changerait
pour vous pourquoi ses démesures vous
souhaitez porter qui pourrait être
intéressante si on baisse la tva à 5,5
au coude sud on va descendre de 20
centimes d'euro le prix du carburant à
la pompe ce qui nous ramène à un prix un
peu plus élevé que celui de l'espagne et
donc on est encore dans les valeurs
régionales et on peut penser que cette
baisse momentanée de la tv ainsi le prix
du baroque du baril revient à des plus
normaux on pourra revenir aussi à une tv
en plus normal j'arrête là il faut pas
être
idiot il faut pas être bloqués sur la
dessus surtout il ya de l'argent puisque
plus le prix du baril augmente avec
cette tva aux pensionnaires plus les
caisses de l'état se remplissent donc il
ya certainement de l'argent est
redistribué pour passer ce cap chaque
heure difficile merci daniel qui est
heureux d'avoir été avec nous
mais je le rappelle dirigeants de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes
[Musique]
et des champions mobiliser contre les
noyades ils étaient réunis ce lundi à
poissy autour du double médaillé d'or
olympique yannick agnel le tout dans le
cadre de l'opération nageur est citoyen
qui vise à développer l'apprentissage de
la natation chez les jeunes de 6 à 12
ans deux cent cinquante neuf enfants ont
pu ainsi être apprendre aux côtés
justement est de ces champions tout en
s'amusant regarder ce sujet de céline
charles
en france c'est un enfant sur deux qui
arrivent au collège sans savoir nager
trois cents enfants de moins de 6 ans
sont également victimes de la noyade
chaque année
face à ce constat sophie kamoun ex
nageuse olympique s'est engagé aux côtés
de sept nageurs de haut niveau dans le
programme majeur et citoyen objectif
apprendre aux enfants à nager et on
s'est dit qu'en tant que anciens
sportifs de nos anciens nageurs de haut
niveau et il était de notre devoir de
mettre notre pierre un petit peu les
lits fissures sur le savoir nager
c'était une cause évidemment nationale
aujourd'hui vous avez 259 gamins du
département qui vont être initiés à la
natation pour certains
conforté dans ce qu'il a à faire pour
pour d'autres la cause de ces chiffres
alarmants l'inégalité d'accès à la
pratique être en contact avec les
enfants qui sont souvent dans des
quartiers
défavorisés si on peut dire c'est à dire
qu'ils ont pas accès aux piscines par
manque de moyens de temps les transports
qui prennent trop de temps nageurs et
citoyens il ya d'un côté la natation
mais aussi toutes ces valeurs de
citoyenneté c'est un enjeu de vie la
natation tout de savoir nager d'abord
pour pour éviter de se noyer cqfd mais
aussi sur les vertus les vertus du sport
démocratiser la natation en s'amusant
c'est la volonté de ses nageurs qui
compte bien rendre cette journée de
partage de transmission plaisante pour
tout le monde c'est extrêmement ludique
le but c'est que les enfants se sentent
bien sentent en confiance pour qu' il
puisse revenir derrière enfin sous on
sort la tête et 26 ans faire l'an passé
après un mec on est jeune âge il sort de
l'eau et après on recommence c'est bien
de là j'ai comme ça on peut apprendre de
nouvelles choses c'est vraiment le but
faire des petits ateliers d'être là avec
eux que ce soit le plus vite possible le
un amusement une partie de plaisir qui
ait aucune contrainte le programme va se
démultiplier dans d'autres villes menthe
et les mureaux vont participer l'année
prochaine et tout le département devrait
être de la partie après les jo de 2024
avant de refermer ce journal un
programme d'études spatiales autour du
globe sept organismes multicellulaires
vivant dans les sous bois l étude est
menée depuis la station spatiale
internationale par le spationaute thomas
pesquet mais pas que quatre mille cinq
cents établissements scolaires travaille
aussi sur le sujet dont le collège
debussy c'est à saint germain en laye
mélanie poké
drôles de bêtes le blob après possession
de la classe de thomas péan professeur
d'arts plastiques au collège debussy
assange en anglais les élèves créent le
temps d'une heure en stop motion bien le
fait qu'on utilise la pâte à modeler moi
j'ai sahara si cool
c'est trop bien et enfin juste film et
l'évolution disait et tablets en tâchant
de l'habitude des dessins
moi je joue beaucoup l'idée originale et
ben en fait j'ai hâte de voir le
résultat à la fin c'est marrant de se
dire qu'il ya un quelques uns à de plus
hauts que nous qui travaille chez la
même chose que nous en fait celui qui
est le plus haut c'est thomas pesquet le
spationaute français étudie 4 blob lors
de la mission alpha dans l' iss et lève
ton blog est une expérience proposée par
le cnes un projet que le corps
professoral de l'établissement saint
germanois souhaité développer dans
différentes matières c'est aussi un
moyen de les faire manipuler des outils
numériques à des fins créatives
et là c'est aussi une occasion ça va
être une occasion en tout cas de
découvrir l'animation vidéo et comment
fonctionne le cinéma ou les principes du
cinéma avec un certain nombre d'image
par seconde en troisième on étudie
beaucoup la question de l'oeuvre
l'espace et le spectateur ça fait partie
du programme
et je pense que à travers ce projet là
en tout cas il va être question aussi
beaucoup de voir ce qu'on peut produire
en terme d'image est ce qu'on peut voir
aussi en termes de spectateurs au
collège debussy les adolescents vont
élever des blogs et travaille sur cette
thématique tout au long de l'année les
professeurs nous donne rendez vous en
novembre cette fois ci pour un cours de
svt
un sujet de mélanie poquet mais vous
avez sans doute reconnu la voix de
michael almy doro et sachez que vous
pouvez découvrir les autres créations
des élèves de cet établissement ainsi
que les différents projets pédagogiques
menées autour du globe sur le compte
twitter c'est le collège debussy de
saint germain en laye et sachez aussi
que le cnrs a également lancé un projet
de science participative derrière le
blob la recherche qui est ouvert à 10000
apprentis scientifiques voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant nouveau numéro
du 7-8 culture et aux commandes bien sûr
c'est yaga tsongo belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]